okay absolutely very good
david we just want to kind of circle
back for a second first thank you for
joining us and boy oh boy different
situation when we talked
last summer at suncoast talking about
proven protocols to open safely now here
we are at the orleans and boyd gaming
seeing business returning
smiles on faces what does it feel like
as a leader with boyd to see this
i mean it's just so fantastic to see
this i mean it has been such a long and
challenging
road for all of us but to see people
coming back
and having fun again after such a
challenging year i mean
it's it's so fantastic i don't know if
any of us could imagine we'd be here a
year from now
but here we've made it and you know i
think what's going on right now
it's been a very long year a lot of
pent-up demand people have been staying
home they're trying to social distance
they're being safe and now that folks
are getting vaccinated
they can come out safely again there's a
lot of pent-up demand
out there there's a lot of energy and
people want to come out and have fun
again
and you know what there is no place
better for having fun in las vegas
and that this makes it prime time for us
i'm curious with that pent-up demand and
people being
away from their normal life for so long
what are they most drawn to
or is it kind of a collective everything
as you think about all your properties
what are people really gravitating
towards well if you look at what
at the end of the day what do you get at
a casino one of the biggest things you
get at one of our properties is that
social experience you get to be around
people and have fun
with other people and share that
exciting experience together
and that's what people are coming for
they've been at home
and they've been socially distancing
where we've been telling people for so
long
you got to stay home you got to stay
away from other people
you can go back out now if you have the
vaccine you can go back out you can have
fun again
and so that's really what people are
coming back to our properties and that's
what that's what's bringing them out
here and
back to las vegas and so it's just
really exciting to see that to see that
excitement again to see
people out here having fun again and
getting back to what we do best here in
las vegas
when you think about this unprecedented
time what was maybe
the biggest challenge and how did you
transcend it as a company
back when we first talked last year at
the suncoast
we didn't really know what to expect
right i mean this was unprecedented
territory we were reopening our business
from ground from ground zero we had to
introduce all of these safety protocols
because you know you had to keep people
safe
and so that meant doing things like
social distancing it meant
making people wear masks when they come
into your property uh it meant cleaning
everything constantly so you're cleaning
chips constantly you're cleaning
chairs constantly slot machine buttons
so this is just an entire
level of complexity that we never had to
do before
and at the same time our team members
have to be out there
giving their a game because people are
still coming here
they still want to have fun and so they
still have to to
to deliver that experience that our
customers wanted you know what they did
it
they did it they couldn't have done it
better and they kept it going throughout
the whole pandemic and
and brought us to where we're at here
today we couldn't have done it without
them
when you look at your team members i
imagine it's a collective point of pride
talk a little bit about what you think
about what the boyd gaming team did
working together to get through this and
now being able to enjoy some level of
normalcy yeah i mean
look that was such we were asking so
much of them right
because the job itself is already a
challenge you're already focused 100
on giving that great experience all the
time and making sure that the guests are
happy and
that you're meeting what they're looking
for then on top of that you're asking
them
okay you got to make sure they're
wearing a mask when they're on property
okay you got to make sure that we
haven't cleaned that slot machine the
customer just left you got to go ahead
and clean that slot machine constantly
so it's that extra layer that they had
to put on top of what they're doing
already
that's a challenge i mean admit it but
but they did it right they stayed
focused they made sure that
that people are still having fun but
they're being safe
and they did that for six nine months
until we get to the point to where
the restrictions finally lifted and so
we couldn't be prouder
of what they did or what they
accomplished because we asked them to do
a lot and they did a lot and now here we
are at the point
to where the restrictions are being
lifted we can go back to more of that
return to normalcy and it's just such a
very exciting time for all of us
and you mentioned exciting time be it
you know miss nevada in a couple weeks
of competition or the partnership with
hawaiian airlines
talk about some of the exciting things
going on right now with going gaming
i think the most exciting thing
reopening returning to normal we're
reopening a lot of our restaurants we're
welcoming events back both here at the
orleans and across
um across town you know world of
concrete coming back down that was a big
jolt of energy
for las vegas and you know it's kind of
interesting what we saw
is from the day we reopened
to until february the turning point for
the city a turning point for us
as a business what we saw the turn was
really around february
once people started getting those
vaccines once you started seeing shots
and arms as the vaccinations go up
the visitors started going up the people
started coming back they said you know
what
i feel safe now i feel comfortable i'm
going to come back to
avoid property i'm going to start coming
back to las vegas i mean i can only tell
you
i'll use my personal experience here
i'll say a strangest thing i was never
happier to get a shot in my life
than the moment i got that cobit shot
because that was such a liberating
moment because at that moment i was like
it's finally ended it's finally ending
i'm
finally going to be protected from this
this virus that we've been
that's been hanging over our heads for
the last year
and i can go out now and i can start
doing things again i can start seeing
people again
and i think that's the kind of feeling
you've seen multiplied
across las vegas across california
across
arizona across all of our employees
and so all of them are now coming back
and getting back to what they were doing
before but maybe it's
we enjoyed a little bit more now right
because we didn't realize what we were
missing
for all that time until we had it taken
away
and now it's coming back and now we get
this this experience back
and it just feels a little more special
than it did before and it's exciting to
see
and you hear those special comments from
the people that come here the people
that love void gaming properties the
tweets
emails and even comments in person can
you maybe give an example of something
someone has said
at one of your properties since
returning that made you guys feel as a
company like if
we're turning that corner yeah so i will
tell you this you hear it all the time
from our employees because we rely on on
regular customers we're locals property
we have regular customers that we see
them a lot you hear it constantly from
them when they finally see that customer
that they haven't seen in a year
who was at reagan and they finally come
back
and it's like a long lost reunion and
there's just so much joy to see that
customer again and to
build that relationship back again and
you're seeing that
all the time you know you see every day
you see another new customer come back
or another old customer coming back and
you get that reunion again it's such an
exciting moment and you're repeating it
all of the time
all across this city and so that's what
i think is really special see
the chance to see our friends again
it's it's like the opening scene of
cheers it's that kind of thing it
absolutely is i mean yeah i mean
we have so many of the of our customers
that are regulars they come here for
that experience because they
are our team members know who they are
and so having the chance to come back
again
and to see their friends here at the
orleans and across town again
that's neat because it reminds us that
of what we are
in business for and it's just such a
very exciting moment
this special is all about community
pride yeah boyd a big part of the
community talk about how
and really also subsequently how our
community kind of
has really come together of recently it
was just so inspiring to see
when we were in those initial dark days
of the pandemic
how the community just came together and
the companies of las vegas and people
las vegas came together to help
so boy gaming what we did is three
squares one that we're really proud of
uh you know we we had food that was
going to go to waste we got it over to
three square so we donated tens of
thousands of pounds
of food to three square to make sure it
was being distributed in the community
um we hosted a covent testing site here
at the orleans
later on we donated 150 000 to 3 square
and then to this day we've been doing it
since late last year and to this day we
host
a feud a food distribution center
at the east side cannery on boulder
highway so twice twice a week
we have three square three square coming
out to the east side to distribute food
in our community
because it's getting better
but there are still those in need we i
think we
got a wake-up call that there is great
need in our community
and that organizations like three square
who are who did such great work in the
community
they still need our help and so you know
at the end of the day las vegas is our
home
boyd's been here for more than 45 years
now
you know we're proud this is our home
and so when the community was in need
we felt it's our duty it's our
obligation we have to step up to help
and but you know it wasn't just us it
wasn't just us it was this entire
community it was entire gaming industry
it was the entire community stepping up
to help
and that's why we were able to get
through this uh pandemic i think
as we wrap up we hear the music jamming
we hear the machines alive with people
gambling and almost perfect timing there
we heard a big bellow by somebody who
clearly just wants some money
and some cheers david i think we're back
i think we're back i mean you know look
it's
there's still ways to go we still want
to see more
convention business in town we still
need to see our international
friends come back but you know what
we've made a ton of progress in 2021
vegas is coming back it's exciting to
see
and i'm just so optimistic as we look
ahead well we're glad to have boyd
gaming a part of the community a part of
this special and we thank you for your
time
thanks brian i appreciate it